- The only way DeSantis
is going to become
the Republican nominee
is if Trump chooses
not to run and
endorses him or dies.
Like I just don't see a world
in which Trump says I want it.
Let's say he says, I want it,
and DeSantis beats him fair
and square in the primary.
You really think the
(indistinct) is gonna abandon
Trump for DeSantis?
They're not.
(soft music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
joining me today is the host
of the "Megyn Kelly
Show," Megyn Kelly.
Megyn, I just said
your name three times.
That's four, if I say
Megyn one more time.
How are you?
- I'm great, how are you?
- Good, I realize
that's quite an intro
if I say this is the host
of the "Megyn Kelly Show,"
Megyn Kelly and then I wanna
say your name to bring you in.
- Yeah, it's a lot.
- So, it's a lot of Megyn's.
A lot of Megyns
- Okay.
- But I got you.
How you doing sister?
- Appreciate it.
What's going on?
- I'm doing great, all is well.
I'm excited, this has
been a great news cycle.
It always makes me happy and
my kids are in a good place
now, so that makes me happy too.
All is well.
- Let's do the kids stuff first.
You fled New York City,
you're in the
suburbs over there,
but you still are in the
tri-state area, let's say.
Are you protected
enough from the insanity
just by leaving Manhattan?
- I'm, yes I am.
And I'm so excited, I'm
so thrilled we did it.
You know, we've talked
about the awfulness
of the New York City
private schools before
and how hardcore left they went.
I mean, hardcore asking my boys,
and they're all boys
school regularly,
if they were sure
they were still boys,
that school no longer
refers to boys as boys.
They call 'em your student,
go collect your student.
They don't say, son.
This was one of the more
traditional schools in the city.
That's why we chose it.
If we wanted far left, we
would've gone to Dalton.
We chose one that
was more traditional,
but it went hardcore at
the thing about, you know,
race essentialism.
And in every classroom
where white children learn,
there's a future killer cop.
I mean, they went far left.
So, we peaced outta
there pretty quickly.
And we found this
school in Connecticut,
when we did our homework of
course, still boys and girls.
Cause I have two
boys and a girl.
And my boy's school in
particular has been outstanding.
My little guy says
the pledge every day.
We went to the annual
dinner where they, you know,
say hello to all the parents
just the other, last week.
And the head of school
stood out there and said,
"We are unabashedly
pro-American here."
- [Dave] Hmm.
- "And we do not believe
in equity of outcome.
We believe in equality
of opportunity
and we don't believe in teaching
these boys what to think.
We wanna teach
them how to think."
Like I, Dave, you or I
could have written this
as the ideal ethos
for our school.
And so I was, I mean a
single tear was running.
I'm like thank god, thank God.
Our girls' school's been
better than where she was.
I wouldn't say it's quite
as great as the boys,
but we're working on it.
- Do you feel undue pressure
when you send your kids
to a school?
I mean, you're Megyn
Kelly, every administrator,
teacher, and all
the other parents,
they're gonna know who you are.
They're gonna know that if
they overstep on something
or if they have an odd policy,
there's a good chance
you're gonna talk about it.
That's gotta be a kind
of delicate balance
cause you also wanna keep your
kids private and all that.
- Well, I don't talk about
what schools we're at
or even what city we're in
because I really have had
some very dark security issues
in my past as an anchor.
So, just as a security
measure, I don't do that.
And so, I wouldn't
be embarrassing the
school, it would,
it would take a
massive fall down.
Even when I left the
New York City schools,
I haven't named them, I don't
talk about them by name.
I don't, I'm not, my goal's
not to embarrass anybody,
but if they cross the line
far enough, I would have to,
It's definitely, you know,
an arrow in my quiver
and hopefully they
won't necessitate it.
You know, I, I will say
like if something happens,
I, I've become a squeaky wheel.
You know, there there
was a memo that went out
by one teacher citing
(indistinct) and
anti-racist this.
And I mean, immediately
I was on the horn like,
what's this?
This, and the school
was already on it.
They had already
taken care of it.
They were two steps ahead of me.
So, I knew I was
in the right place,
but I can't really
worry about that.
And I will say if I
speak out publicly,
cause I, for example,
in my daughter's school,
they were looking for
a new head of school
and we went to all the meetings
and I listened to
every single candidate
and what she was saying
on, you know, their vision.
And I asked all the
tough questions about
diversity, equity,
inclusion, the lovely
name that doesn't match up
in practice.
And I had so many parents come
to me after the fact saying,
"Thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you."
You know, it's like,
you know how it is
when you're out there,
like you're out there with
your opinions and so am I.
People are grateful
cause they're still stuck
on the other side.
They don't feel like
they can especially touch
those third rails.
And so they feel
really validated when
they hear somebody
who's, who can do so.
- I can only imagine that
like a school board meeting,
how they're all staring at you.
Like, Megyn will do it,
we can just, we can just
kind of sit back here.
She'll, she'll take care of it.
Do you think your politics
have shifted at all
in the last couple of years?
Like, I think you and I,
as much as I can think of
anyone in a public sphere,
I think we're like pretty
darn close on things
and whatever the
differences are,
it just doesn't matter in terms
of being human and friends.
But you know, as things
have spun outta control
over the last couple of years,
do you think you've
shifted on certain things?
- Well, I almost feel
like I'm kind of the same,
but the ground
shifted beneath me.
You know, I didn't
like, radically change
my own positions,
but they've started to
mean different things.
I used to think I was
more liberal socially,
but I can't say that now
because what that means now is
you're pro this
radical trans agenda
and you're pro
race essentialism.
I'm not pro any of that.
It used to mean
like, I don't know,
just an entirely
different field of things.
And I used to be more
pro national security
and sort of the national
security apparatus.
You know, I'm Gen
Xer, experienced 9/11
on a personal level.
Mm, things have
changed there too.
I definitely think the far
farther we get from 9/11
the less we need a
lot of those tools.
And the more I see
them being abused,
my feelings about federal
law enforcement agencies
like the FBI, have changed
as we've learned
more information.
So, I feel like the
world has shifted
and my opinions of it
have changed accordingly.
But I remain non ideological.
You know, I'm, at heart,
I'm a soulless lawyer
who wants to be
persuaded with facts.
And if you come to
me with better facts,
instead of saying,
oh, I was wrong.
I'll say hallelujah, I've
learned something new.
I'm smarter today
than I was yesterday.
So, I'm not ideological,
I'm certainly not a knee
jerk Republican or Democrat.
I'm still a registered
independent and
remain open minded.
- Do you think that can
work, the independent thing,
like in sort of real politic?
I know it can work for you
privately and personally,
but like that in terms of just
this craziness that we're in,
it's either like, we're
gonna usher in more
of this woke stuff or
maybe we can stop it.
But the middle thing
is just getting,
- Well, it depends,
- Is just getting harder
to hold, in a way.
- Middle's not the right word.
Independent is different,
independent is just,
I think non-ideological
and open to calling BS
on both sides.
But I'll give you an example.
I went to a one of these
like events where you show up
and you have deep conversations
and people buy a
ticket to listen.
And one of the guys who was
there who spoke near when I did
was Andrew Yang.
And I like Andrew Yang a lot.
I don't agree with him
on most of his positions,
but he's the kind of
democratic I could get behind.
Tulsi Gabbard, she's
the kind of Democratic
I could get behind.
In no world do I ever see
myself backing somebody
like Matt Gates for president.
You know, I could never
back somebody like AOC,
Marjorie Taylor Greene is
not my cup of tea, you know?
So, I don't know, you know,
like if it were Marjorie Taylor
Green versus Andrew Yang,
I'd probably go with
Andrew Yang, you know,
so, that's what I mean, like
yeah, it could work for me.
I don't know if it's gonna
work for the country,
but for my own personal
politics, I'd be fine with that.
- When you're doing
your show every day,
are there moments of of
frustration or is it just pure,
like you're just getting
the information in
and you kind of comment
on it and talk to people?
Or does it wear on you ever?
'Cause I'm like sort,
for the most part,
I'm pretty much enjoying
the show and all that stuff.
But every now and again,
like I was on, as
we're taping this now,
I was on your show earlier today
and it's like this Kamala
thing with the communities
of color and the equity stuff.
It really was getting to
me, it really was like,
maybe that's a little bit
of the new father thing.
Like I'm feeling this need
for the next generation
suddenly in a new
way or something.
But like these are just
horrible ideas and bad people.
- Yes and these culture wars
in particular really upset me.
And the COVID overreach
really upset me.
The longer it went down.
The thing that made me
the maddest I've been
in probably the
past two years was
the shaming of parents who
wanted the masks off their kids.
Like, you haven't done
your part, you don't care,
you know about society
and the old people.
And it's like,
we've done our part,
our children have done our part.
This has been an absolutely
senseless exercise,
what you're doing to these kids.
And finally parents had
to stand up and basically
raise the middle finger and say,
"It's on, whether
we're Democrats or
Republicans, it's on,
we're showing up at your
school board meetings,
we're going to
rhetorically torture you
until you listen to us and
you can call us terrorists,
you can send the FBI
in, we don't give a fig,
we're not going anywhere."
I felt it, so many
parents felt it
and we won that battle.
That's why Glenn
Youngkin won in Virginia.
And it's why the Democrats
almost immediately abandoned
those positions.
They recognized they were all
gonna suffer the same fate
as Youngkin or the governor
Phil Murphy of New Jersey,
who only won by two
or three points,
who he's expected to
win by 30, they got it.
And there's a reasons,
the reason those kids
don't have mask on there,
in the schools right now.
And that, it's
because the parents,
that stuff fires me up, when
the weak or the vulnerable
or the smallest among us
can't fight for themselves.
And the kid thing was really
annoying cause he had people
like Randi Weingarten,
like, "They're resilient.
They don't complain."
They're little, they don't know
how to give voice to this stuff.
Like they're not loud
mouths like you or me.
We're here for them.
Randi Weingarten is
the enemy, I'm sorry,
but she is the enemy of children
and she has to be identified
and treated as such.
And frankly, Dr. Fauci is
in exactly the same camp.
- So, I'm so glad
you just said that
'cause that's where
I was gonna go.
What do we do
about these people?
I am not one for jailing
our political opponents
and I don't wanna throw
'em in (indistinct)
and all the things that they
probably wanna do to us.
But when you look at somebody
like Randi Weingarten,
who's now taking the
reverse of all the positions
or claiming that she took,
is taking the reverse
of all the positions
she had for two years.
And Fauci who, you know,
not wearing masks
at a baseball game,
while telling us to wear
a mask, all this stuff.
Everyone knows all this stuff.
What do we do with these people?
Like publicly?
What should happen, because?
- They need to be
publicly shamed over
and over and over.
And I really think this
is one hopeful thing
about the Republicans
taking the House,
which we believe they will.
I mean, it would take a
massive disaster between now
and the election day for the
Republicans to lose the House.
But they're gonna
investigate Fauci.
And I know he went out
there and said like,
"I'll consider it
if they play nice.
I didn't appreciate the
way I was treated before
and I would expect to be treat."
You'll show up and
you'll sit down
and you'll answer the questions
or you will be found in
contempt of Congress.
That's how this works.
You don't get to say,
maybe I'll come, right.
That's what a subpoena is for.
So, we could get
some real answers
if the GOP takes over the
House and investigates
the COVID origins and more,
maybe not more importantly,
but equally importantly,
the coverup by our
public health officials.
What the hell went wrong
at the CDC and the NIH
and how did they become
such huge behemoth godlike
institutions in the eyes of
the media and the liberals
to where their
quote, "Science TM,"
could not be questioned?
Because it's still
happening, Dave,
I mean I, I'm preparing
for a big interview
that's gonna hit soon and I'm
neck deep in this right now.
The vaccines and the
information about the damage
that the vaccines are doing
versus their efficacy, is dark.
It's not turning out the way
even vaccine proponents like
yours truly wanted it to.
Why is it being buried?
Why can't we talk about it?
Even journals like
"Science and Nature"
and "New England
Journal of Medicine,"
are starting to
release the studies
showing that there's a real
risk in taking the vaccine.
And then you get COVID after
you've taken the vaccine.
These are dark times, they
can take you to dark places.
And there's not an
acknowledgement by
people like Fauci.
He still wants vaccine mandates.
They refuse to acknowledge
that the vaccine
doesn't stop the spread.
And yet we're still imposing
the mandates as though they do.
And then endangering
people who get the vaccine,
who don't need it,
who then will probably
get COVID anyway,
'cause it doesn't protect you
from getting the transmission.
So, you're really messing
with your immune system
in dangerous ways, they
won't acknowledge it.
The only answer is public
accountability, an outcry.
- Wasn't it also amazing how
it's like we had this federal
mask mandate on the planes
and then one judge in Tampa
is like, "No, no, no more."
Everyone takes the
masks off the next day
and there's no spike in COVID,
there's no sudden outbreak
on a plane that's, you know,
taking it over to
Europe or vice versa.
And, but we don't really
stop and acknowledge that
boy they just, the week
before Fauci was like,
"Yeah, we should extend
it on the planes."
- Yeah, I know, God
bless that judge.
And some people,
even on the rights,
some lawyers I respect
ripped her opinion.
I was like, "You know
what, it's a great opinion.
I totally agree with it."
And it stood, right now it
stands and we've been fine.
We've been fine.
I don't think the masks
are gonna come back.
I really don't.
Except for in like really
crazy leftist cities,
maybe New York City, you know,
maybe LA, I don't think
they're coming back
because people have
seen with their children
how damaging that is.
You know, they, I still see
people in the New York area
riding around with a mask
in the car by themselves.
But I think for the most
part we're done doing it
on a mandatory
basis for children.
The vaccine mandate though
it's still in a lot of places.
- I think you said before that
you were a vaccine proponent.
Does that mean that you're
not a vaccine proponent now?
- Yes it does.
I was never a pro-mandate,
but in the beginning I thought
the vaccine was a miracle.
You know, I was proud
of American industry
for coming up with
this thing so soon.
And the first version
of the vaccine
seemed like the best
one because there was,
I believe still, some
measure of protection,
against the spread of COVID.
And so, that particular vaccine
worked fairly well against
that original version of COVID.
And it's just gone steadily
downhill since then.
And so, now I've got
some serious questions
about efficacy,
about dangers, yes, side
effects from the vaccine,
but also what are we doing
to our immune systems
and other body bodily systems
when we take the vaccine
that won't prevent
us from getting COVID
and then we get COVID?
So, now you've had at
least a double shock
to your immune system.
There are questions about
what it actually does,
if anything to DNA, there
have been denials and so on.
But more and more information
is starting to come out now,
as you would expect,
we're two years into
having the vaccines
and you can't trust the
American Public Health Services.
They have only one mission,
which is to push
more vaccines on us.
You have to start getting
your information from the UK,
from Sweden, some, from
Finland, from Israel.
Like there are
countries who are taking
honest looks at this, sadly,
we're not one of them.
- And by the way, every
country you just mentioned,
I mean they're making
mistakes too, right?
Like even you can get your
information from pretty much
everywhere and even
then it's like,
it's hard to tell what's true.
- But I don't trust the
people who never revise
their opinions after
new data comes in.
- Right, right.
- You know, and I mean
seriously, like there's now,
like in the UK, you're
not supposed to,
they're not recommending
the vaccine.
They don't, they won't give it
unless there're special
circumstances to kids under 12.
Here at our school,
there's a mandate in place.
Now, it doesn't kick
in until you're 16,
but there are still school
systems in the country
where you have to get it under
age 12 or you're expelled.
That's what's happening
in Washington DC.
They just had to hold off on it
'cause it was gonna lead to
half of their population.
And that's a black
school population,
that wasn't gonna be
able to go to school.
So, they cared
about that, right?
But they're mandating
it now for young people
when we really have no
idea whether it's actually
gonna lead to increase
in cardiac events
for young children,
myocarditis and beyond.
I featured friends of
mine, Dave, on my show,
friends of mine who I
got to know at the beach.
They're 17 year old son died
suddenly of a heart attack,
of a heart incident
caused by myocarditis.
He wasn't sick, he had
COVID and he had the vaccine
and the family doesn't know,
they don't know what
led to his death,
but he was perfectly
able bodied, five months
after he got the
vaccine and about a year
after he had COVID, he
died of myocarditis.
There's just been too
many incidents like that.
And if you look at the
rise in cardiac events
amongst young people now,
it's disturbingly high
and it seems to follow...
If you look at the graphs
in these magazines,
I've, so these aren't like far
left or far right magazines,
they follow spikes in
the vaccination rate.
They don't follow
spikes in COVID
like the outbreak of Omicron.
It's not like all the cardiac
deaths were happening then
amongst the young people,
they have been following the
increases in vaccination rates,
country to country.
So look, all of that disturbs
me and gives me pause.
And as a journalist it
says, I wanna know more,
I wanna know more and I
know where not to look.
I will not look at Rochelle
Walensky or Anthony Fauci
or anybody at the
NIH or the WHO,
I mean Fauci just gave another
grand to Peter Daszak group,
EcoHealth Alliance,
another 600 plus thousand.
It's gonna go up to 3.3 million,
to do more bad coronavirus
research in China.
These are the people that
we're looking to for answers?
No.
So, I'm still looking
for the perfect advisor,
but I know that
they're overseas.
- And as I'm sure you
saw Fauci's net worth
increased by $5 million
in the last two years.
That's bizarre.
- And why is it that a
public health official
can get a million dollar
award in a role like his
for speaking truth to power?
That's disturbing, right?
Like-
- He has the highest salary
in the federal government
and the highest
retirement salary.
- Well, so, he can
basically be bought,
all you have to do is come up.
Well maybe Pfizer's
gonna give him
the next million dollar award
for speaking truth to power.
But the coziness between
Big Pharma, the media
and the larger government has
not worked to our advantage.
And the, and the media, you
know, I interviewed RFK Jr.
And he was making the
point about how the,
Big Pharma owns the media.
He's not wrong.
If you look at who advertises
all over broadcast media
and cable, it is,
it's drug companies.
- It's Pfizer, did you
ever see that compilation?
Have you ever seen
that compilation from
the morning show?
Oh, I got, I'll text
it to you after this.
There's an incredible,
it's like a three
minute compilation
of all of the news shows,
ABC, NBC, CBS, CNN,
everybody all going in
and outta commercial
brought to you by Pfizer, as
they're reporting on Pfizer.
- You can't.
And they're, they're so rich,
it's an unlimited spend.
You know, it, these
companies are businesses.
That was one thing I realized
in my 17 years at Fox News.
It was a business, it
was a business first.
It's not a public
service, none of them is.
I mean, Fox is not
unique in that way.
They wanna put on
programs that rate,
they're not looking
to do in depth reports
on homelessness, if they
don't think it's gonna rate.
I remember the terrible
earthquake down in Haiti
and our biggest conclusion
looking at the fall
in numbers was Haiti no ready.
Like that's, I remember
we talked about it
because it was just, the
drags in terms of numbers.
And very quickly we and CNN
and everybody else moved off
of Haiti.
Why?
Because we didn't care
about people in Haiti?
No, it's just so far away
that the American consumers
weren't interested
in that story.
And so if we were truly
just a public service,
we would've stayed on
it, but news is not.
And so we all moved
on pretty quickly.
- Do you feel like,
what level of freedom do you
feel now doing your independent
thing that you didn't feel
either at Fox or at NBC?
- I mean, complete freedom.
Complete now.
I can say whatever I want
about whatever I want
or whomever I want.
And that's lovely because,
while Fox censored me
far less than anybody
else ever did,
I mean mean NBC was far worse
than Fox when it came to,
this is how you have to say it
and this is the way we want
it, you know, approached.
Yeah, can you give me
- You understood-
- An example of that?
Like that type of thing
that you were getting,
you were getting at NBC?
- Well, I mean everything,
everything outta your
mouth at NBC is controlled.
You, on my morning show,
you'd have scripts, you know,
that they put in the prompter
and everything would be run
by standard and practices.
So, the lawyers comb
through every word
with a fine tooth comb,
would wanna change,
especially we did a lot
of these me too stories
that were breaking at the time,
which wanna change it to
this or change it to that.
And I, as a lawyer to be,
a lawyer would be like,
that's not necessary,
that's overreach
or were airing too far
on this side or that.
And I was not in control,
they were in control.
Then I would wanna
ask my own questions
because that's all I
had ever done at Fox.
Nobody writes your
questions at Fox
and they would get upset.
They wanted the producers
to write my questions.
And that's where I said,
I'm not doing that.
That I draw the line, that's
literally what you're paying me
for, to use my brain and
come up with questions.
I had one case we were
discussing a Supreme Court case
and a producer had given me a
packet, she was not a lawyer,
they had just hired
her from Al Jazeera.
And she wanted me to answer,
to ask her questions.
This like toddler from
this other, wanted.
I'm like, okay, I
practiced law for 10 years.
I cover the high
court for three years
and I've been a
journalist for 17.
You could take a seat, I
will ask my own questions.
So that, that was a
frustration at NBC
and by the way I did.
At Fox, it was more
understood, you know,
and I was on board
with the Fox mission,
that they were an antidote to
the left wing bias in media.
If you're gonna
work at Fox News,
your goal is not to pick
up the New York Times
and put it on TV,
your goal is to try to take
another look at the stories
that are out there and see
what the media's missing,
see if there is another
side to be told.
And sometimes there isn't,
but usually there is.
So yeah, that's, but
that's not my mission
in my current job.
My current job is just
to give my honest take
on the days news, no
matter where it lands
and however the agenda
is, I don't care.
Like the viewers will
come or they won't.
But it's, it's honest and it's
definitely not ideological.
- Do you wish that at some
level mainstream media
was better?
Or at this point, do you
think the ship has just sailed
and it's like people
will find you now,
they'll find me and
for better or worse,
we're all just gonna go in
our directions and so be it?
- I think it's over
for them, it's over.
You know, they're, they're
gone but not forgotten.
And I think they're just on
their last legs right now,
sort of wobbling around about
to fall and be, and it's,
I just think it's done for them.
I think it's too late
to resurrect them.
So, today we talked
about Chris Cuomo
and his new show and he
goes out there and he says,
on NewsNation, I, I'm gonna
be sort of the moderate voice.
Okay, I'm gonna be
the voice of reason.
Who's gonna give it to
you in a nonpartisan,
give me a break.
CNN, right now is trying
to do the same thing.
After all these years
of telling everyone
who's in the center
or right of not just,
we're not with you, we hate you.
Now, that they see that, that's
a failing business model,
they wanna turn
everything around and
say, you can trust us.
We're in the middle,
we're the voice of reason.
Bullshit, nobody believes that.
So, that works to your
advantage and to my advantage
because I think in
both of our cases,
we have a history of not
being blinded by ideology.
We've been open to facts
and new information
and honest about that
journey too with our viewers.
So, that's our advantage,
it's not theirs.
And I don't think the
media's gonna come back
from what they did to
themselves during Trump.
- As I always say on
the show, it's like,
for better or worse, whatever
I'm saying on the show
is coming out of my mind.
So, it's like it
all falls on me.
But one of the things
I'm always amazed about
is on the network side,
that these guys that screw up
or get caught in massive lies
or their ratings are horrible,
they barely get fired.
They just get shifted, so Brian
Williams, NBC Nightly News,
I don't even remember what
it was he got fired for,
He lied about something.
- For all the lies,
he told all the lies about,
I remember he was like,
basically with SEAL Team Six
at the Bin Laden Compound
- Oh, right,
that's what it was,
they were shooting,
- Helping.
- So then he gets
fired from that gig
and they give him a show
on MSNBC, Don Lemon,
no one's watching, says
crazy things every night.
They take him off prime time.
They put him in the morning.
Like it's almost like
they're showing us
how insane the whole thing is.
- Yeah, well they,
they don't care.
Cause those people are on
the right side ideologically,
which is the left, right?
Like they would've gotten
rid of them a long time ago
if they hadn't been
saying the things
that the network executives
wanted them to say.
I mean, the Don Lemon
case really brings it home
because as soon as they
had a shift in management,
he literally went out on the
air and reminded everyone
that he's black
and he's gay, he,
like that's where we
are in our society.
- Yeah.
- Just in, I mean I should
have tried this at NBC.
I should have been like,
just in case you're thinking
about getting rid of me,
I have a vagina, just want
you to know, just that's.
- Megyn, if I'm not mistaken,
a former president once
talked about your vagina,
so, you know.
- Yeah, as you might
know, I've got one.
And it's so pathetic
though, right?
And so, why did he do that?
Because it works.
It, they didn't keep
Don Lemon at CNN
because they thought we'll
build a show around him
in the morning,
that was his excuse.
They're gonna build
something around me.
I'm like, more about
you than your own show
in the prime time with your
name and only your name on it?
Because guess what,
Don, this is a demotion.
In any event, they
did it because he's
in the right identity
boxes and he's thinker of
the kind they like, right?
He's not a, he's not a
black gay conservative.
That would be a bridge too far.
They're not gonna
take Christian Walker
and put him in the
Don Lemon slot.
Anyway, so he's got
all that going for him.
And the same thing
with, you know,
somebody like a Chris Cuomo
who stayed a lot longer
than he should have, right?
Because he's somebody who
thinks the way they do
and he's tied to the
larger Cuomo Empire.
- It's funny 'cause I heard
Chris Cuomo say the thing about,
I'm gonna be the voice
of reason of something.
And it's like, well
what were you doing?
What do you think you did
for the last five years?
I mean,
- Yeah.
- What are you admitting?
Or if you're gonna
admit it then admit it.
Do the full Mea Culpa,
- Here's the thing-
and maybe we can-
- No, it was a lie.
He Mea Culpad over
protecting his brother,
not over being a partisan hack,
turning himself
into a (indistinct)
without admitting it
- That's what I mean.
That's what I mean.
- Here's what's annoying.
Like when I was at Fox News,
I would make headlines a
lot inadvertently, you know,
the media would just pick it up
because I, I'd have
very contentious moments
with very well known
Republicans, right?
From Newt Gingrich,
to Dick Chaney,
to Donald Trump and beyond.
But I would also make
a lot of headlines
for the fights I
had with Democrats,
from Donna Brazile to
Anthony Wiener and beyond.
I have a history I
can actually point to,
to tell the audience I will
challenge any politician
you've put in front of me
because I'm not blinded
by my own political opinions.
What can Chris Cuomo
point to in his past
that would back up his, I'm the
voice of reason to trust me,
to not get sucked into the
harsh partisanship of TV news.
Bullshit, it was a lie
because he needs to turn over
a new leaf.
And so, he needs to hope and
pray that people don't believe
their lying eyes that
they've looked through
for the past 12
years or however long
he was there doing that.
- So, speaking of Chris Cuomo,
you are a former New Yorker.
They got rid of his brother
in the midst of this COVID
craziness and I don't
know if you know this,
but it, so it happened
during August,
last August when
they got rid of him.
So, I didn't know about
it for a couple weeks
'cause I'm off the grid and
then Corolla is bringing me back
on the grid and
he says, you know,
they got rid of Andrew Cuomo
before he even said who,
which, he was being
replaced with.
I said, "I guarantee
you whoever it is,
it's going to be worse."
And it's fairly obvious
that Kathy Hochul
is far even despite the fact
that he killed all these people
and our friend (indistinct),
what happened to her, you know,
in-laws and all of this stuff.
- Yeah.
- But she's, she's the
worst of the worst.
I mean, are do you think
that New York, California,
these places, do you think
they can ever turn around
or are they just gonna be
perpetually on that slide now?
- Hmm.
I don't know.
Because both New
York and California
have had Republican governors.
They have large pockets
of red, you know,
they're statewide elections
have been dominated by Democrats
for years now, but, you know,
upstate New York
and Long Island,
parts of New York are in western
New York, still very red.
And obviously that's
true in California too.
It just doesn't happen to be
true of their major cities
like New York City and
LA, certainly San Fran.
So, I don't wanna say
it's never possible
to have reason restored.
And it wouldn't have to
be a Republican, you know,
I mean, it could be
an Andrew Yang type
or a Tulsi Gabbard
type Democrat,
somebody who just had it
and was ready to call BS,
I still think as lifelong
New Yorker, you know,
not New York Cityer
but New York Stater.
That could happen in my state.
I have faith in the
reason of most people
living in New York.
You know, I think that
what's happened in New York
and you'd know better
than I in California,
is the loudest voices have
dominated the discussion
and shamed the vast
majority of their party
into going along.
And now that's become policy.
And now we're seeing the real
life results of that policy,
for example, defund the police.
And slowly but surely those
policies are falling apart.
Now, COVID is its own
unique brand of insanity.
Our governor in New York
is wearing a Vaxed necklace
to her public events.
I can't help people
like that, they're gone.
They're too far gone.
We just need a new, a new ruler,
a new governor to replace her.
So, I don't wanna say never,
but probably no time soon.
- I mean, when I heard her say
that line a couple weeks ago
about how republicans don't
share our New York values
and go down to Florida,
it's like I don't know that
I've ever heard a Republican,
a sitting, you know,
in office Republican, say
anything that disgusting
about half the people
that live in their city.
And yet it's becoming sort of
commonplace with the way they,
they speak about
half the country.
- Yeah, well, I mean,
it's like Governor Cuomo
said that too 10 years ago
when he was still in the office.
And I, at least Governor
Cuomo has a name that's been
in New York, we all
loved Mario Cuomo
back in the day.
- Everyone loved Mario Cuomo.
- At least he's got
some like street cred
when it comes to
being a New Yorker.
Kathy Hochul, who are you?
You weren't even elected.
We didn't even want you
with your weird necklace
in your two blushy cheeks,
I don't like, take a seat.
Again, I want her
to just be quiet
and she's become this hardcore
activist, she is awful.
She's the worst politician,
she can't give a speech.
She's, there's nothing
relatable about her.
So, I'm even more
offended by her comments.
And then you got Charlie
Chris down there like,
Don't vote for me if you,
you voted for DeSantis,
like, weren't you a Republican
like two minutes ago?
Like you're even more soulless
and spineless than Cuomo.
So yeah, I don't
think that they speak
for the vast majority
of their party.
I think smart politicians want
most from wherever they come,
but it just kinda shows you
how tribal we've gotten.
- Yeah, so, you know, I'm down
here obviously in Florida now
and it's been a little hard
for me to try to figure out
what's going on with
the mainstream media
when it comes to this hurricane,
but it's pretty obvious, cause
I don't have cable anymore,
so I can't, you know, I
only see Twitter clips now,
but it's pretty obvious.
It's like this machine
would love for this disaster
to have been worse
to get DeSantis.
Do you think that's
too much to say that?
Or do you agree with that?
- No, it's, oh, oh my god.
No, it's definitely
not too much.
The media's capable of anything.
The darkest things you
can possibly imagine,
they're capable of it,
they're very agenda driven.
So, yes and what they're
doing to DeSantis now
in Lee County,
it was like, why didn't
you cover Lee County
he's like, "Well the course
of the hurricane changed
and when it changed we
gave an evacuation order."
And they're like, "Oh,
but it takes 20 hours
for the people on the
outskirts to evacuate."
Well take it up with
Hurricane Ian, right.
And to DeSantis's credit,
he said to the media,
"Where were you?
You weren't in Lee, right?"
- You guys were all in Tampa.
- You were in Tampa,
so like, save it.
But if they smell blood
in the water, you know,
they're gonna, they love
it when it's a Republican.
And, and there was
just a report, I think,
I think it was Maggie Haberman
in the New York Times,
who was saying something like,
"A lot of the times
you have to wait,
you have to wait to
see the damage to know
what kind of a job
the leader has done."
So, it's basically like, so
far he's done a good job,
but just let's hold our
fire because I'm sure
there'll be disasters
popping up that we can blame
on him later.
- God, it, it really,
it's so gross.
It really is just
so absolutely gross.
What do you want to happen
with the Trump, DeSantis thing?
- Well, I just don't think
anybody else could win
if Trump runs, so,
and I don't, I just
I don't know.
- Really, so, you think
if they got on a stage, you
don't think that DeSantis
is crafty enough or the
record stands enough to,
- No, no.
- Really?
Interesting.
- No, I don't even
think that a little,
I think Trump sucks up all
the energy in every room
no matter what.
And even someone is
skilled as a politician
and smart policy wise as
DeSantis, can't overcome that.
He can't, it the only way
DeSantis is going to become
the Republican nominee as
if Trump chooses not to run
and endorses him or dies.
Like, I just don't see
a world in which Trump
says I want it.
Let's say he says I want it,
and DeSantis beats him fair
and square in the primary.
You really think
the (indistinct) is
gonna abandon Trump
for DeSantis?
They're not.
I talk to them all the
time, I take calls from them
on my radio show and they won't,
They, they like DeSantis,
but they don't
think it's his turn.
They think Trump was screwed
out of his last election,
that he was screwed
out of his first term
by all the craziness and
the Russia gate and so on.
And they think he is entitled,
he deserves another shot at it.
And so unless Trump gracefully
and graciously says,
"Get behind DeSantis,"
I wouldn't put any chips
on DeSantis at all.
- That's, that's
really interesting.
I mean look, I've said
many times I'd love,
love for them to work it out
on the DL, have a dinner,
figure out what has to be
figured out and go forward.
A lot of people, and I'm
sort of moving on this
a little bit, say
that they should just
get on the debate
stage and do it
and whoever you know comes
out will be sharper for it.
But I agree there is a certain
portion of like the base base
that would rather
burn everything down
if it doesn't get to Trump.
- But it's a huge portion, Dave.
It's a huge portion.
Like the hardcore Trump faithful
is unshakeable and they're,
I've I, again, I hear
from them all the time,
they're, they like him,
they like DeSantis,
but they would never
cross Trump for him.
And they think that DeSantis
owes his political career
to Trump, like if forced to
choose, they will choose Trump.
So, DeSantis can't
take him down.
It's like the line in War Games,
"The only winning
move is not to play."
DeSantis has got to
either be crowned by Trump
or he shouldn't run.
Is he's Trump, it'll be, it
would be, I, I don't know.
I don't, he it wouldn't,
I was gonna say it's not
gonna be a kamikaze mission
cause he wouldn't
take down Trump.
Only Trump can take down Trump,
but he won't win over
Trump, I'll stand by that.
You can play it against me
if I'm wrong, but I won't be.
- By the way, I'm not even
totally sure I want him to run.
I love Florida so much and
I know how much he loves it
and I know how this state is
flourishing that at some level,
just at a, I suppose at
somewhat selfish level,
it's like, no, stay here.
Let's, keep running with this
thing and see how great we can
make this state.
And maybe the machinery
of the federal government
is just so broken.
That swamp thing maybe
is so all encompassing
that there's not much you
could do there anyway.
- It wouldn't be bad
to vote for gridlock.
- Yeah, at this point-
- It wouldn't be bad
to just freeze the
executive's powers,
which have gotten too big.
- Yep.
- And this, this version of,
the presidency of
the executive branch
was never envisioned
by the founders.
It's gotten too big
and too out of control.
However, if we froze
it as it is now,
if we're voting for
gridlock from, you know,
in 2024, in 2022
and 2024 and beyond,
and then we're gonna be
stuck with a lot of bad Biden
policies and I would love
to see that some of those
reversed, for example,
due process for young man
accused on college campuses.
Which is about to switch
back to Biden's and Obama's
worldview, unless this
public comment period,
which was very anti their
changes, changes things.
But I, you know, he doesn't
want due process for accused men
on campuses.
He wants trans girls
to be competing
against biological
girls in girls sports.
He, there's a lot of
stuff that Biden's done
that needs to be undone.
And then if we could
just like undo it
and put us back to stasis,
then I'm all for gridlock.
You know, I don't
want a big executive.
I'd much rather see
governors make policy
and you know, do police
power things and so on.
- So, since you can
say whatever you think
about all sorts of
stuff these days,
and you mentioned Biden,
do you think he's all there?
What do you think is really
going on here at this point?
Who do you think is
running this thing?
It cannot be him, right?
- Joe Biden is not okay,
there's no question in my mind.
All the signs of dementia
are present and increasing.
It's getting worse by the day.
The being lost all the
time, that's a sign.
The increase in slur,
(indistinct) there's a, hold on,
(indistinct), that's
a sign of dementia.
The inability to remember
who's dead and who's alive.
Even though moments
earlier you saw a tribute
to this representative from
Indiana, Jackie Walorski.
And then you look around the
room and say, where is she?
You just, you just
saw a tribute.
You wrote a letter
to her family.
I realized he didn't do
it, he knew she was dead.
He'd been told it
wasn't just a few weeks,
it was two months earlier.
He forgot, it's a
sign of dementia.
All, even the way we mock
how he says something
and then the White House
comes out a day later
and does the cleanup.
You know, like, no, no, we're
not gonna go into Taiwan
if China invades, we're not.
That's not...
And it depends on if
it's a minor incursion
and oh no, I'm for
regime change in Russia,
all three, you know, right.
His minions at the White
House or his controllers
run out and say, "Didn't mean
it, not a change in policy."
That's part of it.
He's not in control of what he
says, of what he blurts out.
And he's the one who in
that 60 minutes, Dave said,
"Watch me."
- Yep.
- The question by Scott Pelly
was, "Are you fit?"
And he said to us, "Watch me."
Well, we have, we are,
and we're deeply alarmed.
We're coming up on November,
that's when the
annual physical is,
there must be a cognitive test,
the results of which must
be publicly released.
Trump did it in '18
and Biden has to do it.
And it better be with
somebody who we trust
and not some hack.
- I hate to tell you,
but I don't think we're getting
the results of that test
unless, unless, and I
think this is probably
what the move will be,
which is if they get completely
hammered in the midterms,
they're gonna need
the scapegoat.
And you just figure out a way
to just dump it all on Biden.
He has to step down.
And I honestly, I'm not sure
they'd give it to Kamala.
They'd figure out some weird
way to get Gavin Newsome
in there or something.
- No way, they can't
possibly give it to her.
Honestly, like, I'm sorry, but
this is not a smart person.
She's really not, she's
not like, I, sorry, but,
and she may be more prone
to verbal gaffes than he is
without the dementia.
- Right, right.
- At least he's got an excuse.
- Right.
- So, they can't and
they know they can't.
Adam, no, Mark Geragos and
Adam Corolla on my show,
and Mark was saying he thinks
that they may take Karen Bass,
you know, running for
LA Mayor and pluck her,
like replace Kamala Harris
with a different person
who's diverse, who
would check some boxes.
Like the only way to get rid
of Kamala Harris is, you know,
stay in the diverse lane and
maybe get rid of her that way.
I don't know.
I thought the whole thing
was gonna be give her
the Supreme Court judgeship
and turf her out that
way and then open up
that second in command spot.
Now, I don't know.
I know Gavin Newsome has
great hair, I see it too.
- I do.
- He's soulless.
He has no soul.
- There's no soul
behind the hair.
As soon as America gets
a closer look at him
and his policies,
they're going to run.
He's a squad member.
- Yeah.
- That's how far left
he is, he can't do it.
America is still a center
right country, we are,
There's no way Gavin
Newsome becomes president.
Not now, not unless he really
changes all of his policies.
- Isn't it incredible
though that the,
how the media runs cover
for them no matter what.
So like, you know, you
mentioned a couple of Biden's
big gaffes, the the
Taiwan one, for example,
but it's like, do you remember,
what was it six weeks
ago or so that Biden said
he had cancer and then
basically within two minutes,
everybody was like, no, no, no,
it's not that he has cancer,
it's that he has dementia.
So, he just misremembered
the, and it's like,
how do you guys,
they're doing the magic
trick right in front of us
and everybody falls
for it every time.
- Yeah, yeah, well, I mean,
there's one a day, right?
It's like I'm a Puerto Rican.
I was basically raised Puerto
Rican with Puerto Rican.
Oh, you mean in,
in New York state,
which had 0.8% Puerto
Rican population.
You had 3,000 Puerto Ricans
out of $550,000 (indistinct)
and you were raised
by Puerto Rican?
No you weren't.
Right, these like, the
media doesn't care.
They, they actually wind up...
If you try to fact check Biden
on any of these absurd claims,
they run out there and
then they fact check you.
Like Kamala Harris, the thing
that you kicked it off with
and her racist comments about
how you, you have to be a,
a group in need of equity in
order to get hurricane relief.
I think it was The Washington
Post did a fact check
on some senator who
said, "She's making race
the basis for relief."
And they were like, fact
check, lacks context.
Why don't you fact
check her claim?
Cause what she said is a lie.
That White House had to disavow
it, FEMA said it's not true.
Where's that fact check?
- Ugh, we covered it on
my show and we'll continue
to cover it.
Megyn, as I often tell you,
you are on my short
list of sane people,
which keeps getting shorter.
I don't know if that's good
for you or bad for you or what,
but it's good to
see you, my friend.
- It's an honor, great
to see you again.
- And next time over tequila
in the free state of Florida.
- Oh, sounds amazing.
Done, consider it done.
See you there.
- All right, if you're
looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics, check out the
full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.